veamos cómo aplicar la fórmula de
integración por partes para encontrar la
anti derivada de la x coseno de x de x y
recuerda que cuando usamos integración
por partes se trata de encontrar cuál de
estas funciones de este producto de
funciones al derivarse hacia la
expresión más simple pues ni a la x ni
coseno de x al tomar su derivada se hace
más simple ni tampoco cuando tomo su
anti derivada se hace más compleja la
expresión en este caso es como echar un
volado a cuál asignas fx ya cuál que
prima de x de hecho no importa cuál es
tu elección siempre llegas a la misma
solución entonces asignemos como f x
hacia la equis y como g prima de x a
coseno de x vamos a escribirlo acá abajo
tenemos que fx es igual
ayala x importante prima de x es igual a
yale x la deriva con respecto a x de a
la x es la x
por otro lado g prima de x es igual a
con seno de x y la anti derivada de x va
a ser igual a la anti derivada de coseno
de x que es seno de x gx es igual a seno
de x apliquemos entonces integración por
partes esto va a ser igual a fx por gd x
fx que es la x por gd x que es seno de x
y ala x por seno de x y esto - menos la
integral de f prima de x f prima de x es
a la x y a la x x gx que es seno de x
integral de a la x seno de x y todo esto
de x no parece que hayan mejorado las
cosas sólo tenemos un integral en
términos de seno de x pero bueno veamos
qué pasa al resolver esta integral vamos
a resolver este integral también por
partes lo voy a hacer acá abajo tenemos
que la integral de a la x seno de x
de equis y esto que va a ser igual bueno
vamos a asignar vamos a asignar también
como fx a la equis es un integral
diferente pero bueno aquí también
coincide que fx es igual a yale x con lo
cual f prima de x es igual a ya la equis
y entonces gdx gx es igual a seno de x
pero aquí aquí tengo un error porque lo
que necesitamos aquí es que prima de xy
déjame corregir esto déjame corregir
esto lo que tenemos aquí es que prima de
x prima de x es igual a seno de x y por
lo cual gdx es igual a menos coseno de x
la derivada de coseno de x es menos seno
de x la deriva de menos coseno de x es
seno de x
vamos a aplicar entonces la fórmula de
integración por partes
esto es igual entonces a fx porque de x
es decir a la x x menos coseno de x
podemos mejor poner el signo menos por
delante sería menos que a la x por
coseno de x-men o sea la x coseno de x y
esto menos la integral de f prima de x
por gdx efe prima de x es a la x ya la x
x - coseno de x a la x x menos coseno de
x dentro el integral voy a escribir
coseno de xy el signo menos lo voy a
sacar del integral menos por menos es
más por lo cual es positivo el signo
y por supuesto tenemos de equis para
cerrar la integral y aquí podrías decir
oye sal no hemos hecho ningún progreso
esta integral está en términos del
integral original estamos como dando
vueltas aquí tenemos ya el x coseno de x
el original era de a la x coseno de x
estamos dando vueltas al hagamos algo
que es interesante sustituyamos esto de
aquí
sustituyamos esto de aquí déjame
indicarlo de otra manera vamos a
sustituir esta integral que tenemos aquí
aquí donde ya la teníamos originalmente
a ver déjame ver cómo puede indicar esto
la lista mira esto que tenemos aquí que
es el resultado de la integral lo vamos
a sustituir aquí en la expresión
original y veamos qué es lo que sucede
que tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo
es la integral original la anti derivada
que nos pedía la integral de a la x x de
x y esto es igual a ea la x seno de x
y a la equis
x
y menos vamos a restarle esta expresión
vamos a restar esta expresión que
obtuvimos acá entonces al restar menos a
la equis coseno de x tenemos que hay que
sumarle más que a la equis
coseno de x y a la x x y luego al
restarle este integral tenemos que va a
ser menos menos
la integral de a la x - la integral de a
la x
con seno de x de x
ahora esto es interesante que hemos
hecho fíjate encontramos esta integral
la encontramos por partes aquí abajo y
luego los sustituimos acá arriba los
restamos de a la equis seno de x y
obtuvimos esta expresión que tenemos acá
abajo que observa que obtuvimos
obtuvimos una ecuación donde aparece dos
veces la integral que nos están pidiendo
de hecho podemos asignarle una variable
esta integral y tendríamos una ecuación
en esa variable vamos entonces a
despejar la integral sumando el lado
izquierdo la integral de a la x coseno
de xx y también sumando el lado derecho
a la integral de a la x x de x que
resulta del lado izquierdo va a ser dos
veces la integral de a la x coseno de x
de x del lado derecho sería este término
la suma de estos dos términos voy a
copiar y pegar voy a copiar y pegar esto
muy bien para que finalmente esta parte
estos dos términos
se hace en cero y ya podemos despejar
entonces la integral de a la x coseno de
equis de x vamos a dividir ambos lados
de esta ecuación de hecho es una
ecuación vamos a dividir ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre dos del lado
izquierdo al divididos entre dos se hace
uno y nos queda tan solo la anti
derivada de a la x coseno de x de x y
del lado derecho dividiendo entre 2
sería el ax seno de x más ya la x coseno
de x sobre 2 pero ojo lo que estamos
obteniendo aquí es una de tantas anti
derivadas sería realmente una pena
después de todo el proceso que hicimos
de integrar dos veces por partes de
sustituir una de esas integrales en la
expresión original tenemos que recordar
que requerimos la constante integración
ce para obtener la anti derivada general
así que si tú derivas esta expresión sin
importar el valor de la constante vas a
obtener que a la x coseno de x
de hecho viéndolo bien el resultado es
sumamente elegante